I thought that you just wanted to
friends I think we can never be just
friends there chemistry he literally
carries the whole film it's so it's a
romance it's a love story but it is also
a coming-of-age story heartache is part
of coming-of-age it's part of you know
finding out who you are and exploring
yourself and to me finding out also
who's good for you and who's not good
for you right and that's a big part of
after I think that it's better if we
keep our distance what do you guys think
is going to be the most surprising scene
for everyone watching this is always
that's probably gonna be the most
surprising thing for people who haven't
read the books yeah I don't want Simon
to you I know I know but it was a great
other group yeah something's going on
but it's not what you think
surprising part I love Josephine so I
felt bad like especially the scene that
everyone's kind of anticipating where
it's like the big reveal
yes like I felt so bad because I like
she's like literally crying in front of
me and I'm like well I'm supposed to act
like I don't give it like you care like
oh well that's not my fault
and then when it cut it was like are you
okay can I have a hug please because I'm
so sorry I did not mean to make you cry
nothing could ever change the way that I
feel about you
casting the leads Josephine and hero and
that chemistry but they have it's so
undeniable
yeah we've really got really lucky with
that because they didn't have chemistry
reeds together they both had them with
other people what are you dreaming about
but with hero jenni gage and I it was
pretty much like immediate thing when
she saw him she knew when I saw my new
with Josephine she was auditioning for
another character so hearing her say
Molly's lines who is complete opposite
of Tessa I was like why is Tessa
auditioning for Molly it was this weird
thing are you a virgin
I'll do Darren your character particular
wasn't supposed to be a woman can you
talk about when you found out that you
were gonna be playing Tristan after I
auditioned for it I checked out after
and check out the books and I saw
Tristan was a guy in the books and I
just thought it was so cool that you
know they made her a girl for the movie
and I play stuffs girlfriend and the
LGBTQ community is so supportive of me
in music and just in my life and so I'm
so happy to be able to you know play
bring that to life yeah yeah bring it to
life and I'm yeah just talk about the
representation that you guys are showing
on screen with that dynamic by creating
this character into a female and there
not only that but just how Pia is and
how Cammy ochite just embodies that
she's just so sweet and loving in real
life it was just easy for her to take on
this character I think it's amazing and
a great way to pave the way for more
female roles
Tristan like really does have passion
for stuff you know keynesian and I just
connect really well and so I think that
made it so easy for us to portray their
relationship but it's so endearing and I
think the fans are gonna love it when
they watch the movie the casted mitts
there was pressure preparing for a few
key scenes I feel like everyone's been
waiting to see how Landon and Tessa meet
that first meeting is so crucial to the
storyline is there pressure for you yeah
I mean there's always pressure in terms
of people have lived with these
characters and these stories for in this
story this world for a really long time
and so they have you know created an
idea of what it should look like and
what it should be so you know I
definitely wanted to honor that and to
honor you know their expectations I
think we can never be just friends
the lake scene is my favorite in the
whole film and it's one of my favorites
in the book too so I was really scared
with that scene going in because on
Wattpad you can literally see the most
commented on parts of the whole story we
had data behind it so we knew that's
literally like the fan favorite as well
so there was a lot of pressure to get it
right once we were actually filming it
just came so naturally to everyone the
first day filming was such a beautiful
day the second one we had like this
thunderstorm and you'll never see it in
the film but it was everything that I
wanted it to be in their chemistry just
it's incredible and in that scene you
really seen like literally the moment
that he looks at her and everything
starts changing and that scene is I
think it's gonna be a fan favorite
absolutely that's the moment after and
yeah our life is changing it's the first
time that Tessa says yes she says yes to
hearten and says okay let me let me see
let me explore what this is what this
these feelings are and that's why that
scene is so important to me
their favorite scene was the lake scene
is there one that stands out in your
mind that was amazing the shoot it was a
scene it was not only the getting ready
scene but it was also the one before you
were getting ready when I went into the
library to tell they're like we're going
out we're going out we should go but
Tessa and hardens chemistry isn't the
only relationship to look out for Joe
and I are like like legit close we
talked about acting talked about life
you know Landon and Tessa are close and
there's no other motive right you know
he just he has her back he is he is that
rock he loves with everything that he
has and doesn't judge and it seems
promising that there will be an after
part two yeah I think there's a lot of
talks about having at least one sequel
if not more absolutely and where do you
think we'll pick up in the storyline
well I don't know okay yeah but they're
obviously they have some work to do on
the relationship
in the next installment I'm sure they
could start from so many different
places the way that it ended and the way
that the whole moving lint I mean it's a
broad spectrum of where they can pick it
back up from so I hope they do well if
people watch this movie you would get a
second one so we don't know yet yeah we
was pretty mature we'll see we were not
sure yeah
[Music]